-Unwind your mind
as we journey deep
into the mystic forest realm
to discover...
♪♪
-Hello! I'm Goat Leg Greg!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is "Pearls of Wisdom
with Goat Leg Greg."
Gilvin of the Tree,
show yourself!
-'Tis I!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Recorder plays ]
Gilvin of the Tree!
[ Laughter ]
Commence thy pearls, Greg!
Enlighten us with your thoughts
about "The Bachelor"!
[ Recorder plays ]
-There's 30 young ladies,
15 are named Katie,
all searching for Mr. Right.
I watched the first few
but slept halfway through.
'Cause Zach is boring
as [bleep].
[ Recorder plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Giggling ]
That's a good one, Greg!
The truth is what thou speaketh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Recorder plays ]
Now delight us
with your brilliant take
on that which we call...
spring break!
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Recorder plays ]
-Spring break is here.
It's that time of year.
A week full of fun
and debauchery.
If you make a love connection,
you best use protection,
or you'll get a rash
down in your de-crotch-ery.
[ Recorder plays ]
-[ Giggling ]
That's a classic, Greg!
You speaketh what the rest of us
merely doth thinketh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Recorder plays ]
You're the real GOAT.
Greatest of All Time
Topical Talker.
Now...opine --
[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Now opine, if you will,
about Shamrock Shakes!
[ Recorder plays ]
-Shamrock Shake, Shamrock Shake.
Oh, how it quenches me thirst.
It's green and bright
but looks just like
Baby Yoda got the squirts!
[ Recorder plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know it to be true, Greg!
Oh, how your words
tickle the tongue
with the titillating tales...
of tantalizingly torrid
totally toads!
Bravo, Greg! Bravo, I say!
Ha ha ha!
Bravo to you!
-Gilvin, Gilvin, enough!
It is time for my final pearl.
-Ooh! [ Giggles ]
[ Recorder plays ]
The final pearl!
Commence thy final pearl, Greg!
Oh, do one about
the Cocaine Bear.
[ Recorder plays ]
-There once was a bear
on cocaine.
The forest creatures
thought him insane.
So he quit coke right there,
met Smokey the Bear,
and lit up some sweet mary jane!
[ Recorder plays ]
-That was it! That was it!
That's the one!
You did it, Greg!
Ha ha ha!
[ Recorder plays ]
-Farewell, Gilvin!
Farewell, Gilvin!
And farewell --
-Aah!
-Gilvin. Gilvin.
Are you alright? Gilvin?
Gilvin, are you --
[ Laughter ]
Gilvin?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you alright?
Farewell to you all!
This has been "Pearls of Wisdom
with Goat Leg Greg."
Stick around.
We'll be right back.
We're talking to Brendan Fraser.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪